la energía de tiempos de guerra sigue
siendo el centro del debate entre rusia
y la unión europea el g7 pacto y poner
límites al precio del petróleo ruso
alegando que con este financian la
invasión como después la estatal gazprom
anunció la suspensión indefinida del
nord stream 1 el gasoducto que antes de
la guerra proveía el 35 por ciento del
gas que consume toda la unión europea la
sola noticia hizo disparar en un 28% los
precios del suministro en el bloque
además el cierre del principal grifo
preocupa en el 'viejo continente' ante
el invierno que se avecina para analizar
la crisis energética nos acompaña desde
parís gabriel jiménez analista y
profesor de economía en pneuma business
school gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 y desde el inicio de la guerra
la unión europea se trata solamente de
llenar sus reservas previendo
precisamente cortes de suministro por
parte de rusia
el objetivo era llenarlas a un 80 por
ciento de noviembre y ahora en esta
están a un 82 por ciento es esto
suficiente o que tanto siguen afectando
los cierres de los principales
oleoductos
o sea por el momento bueno tenemos
tiempo pero nos queda solamente ya dos
meses para que empiece a ser frío frío
pero dependiendo de los países en europa
también depende de cada país hay países
que tienen más reservas que otros
francés por ejemplo ya está a por lo
menos 90 publicitó en sus reservas ya
bien llenas mientras que otros países
tienen más dificultad como en el caso de
alemania bueno y algunos gobiernos ya
están reaccionando y estaban anunciando
paquetes de ayudas para los ciudadanos
fue el caso de alemania que prometió un
paquete de 64 mil dólares y se espera
que el nuevo gobierno británico de
listos haga lo mismo con un paquete de
115 mil millones de dólares es esto
suficiente para paliar la crisis
energética
bueno a corto plazo sí pero el problema
es que más estos se alargan más
necesitarán gastar no de dar más ayudas
y el problema va a depender después de
las finanzas públicas de cada país para
alemania sigue siendo fácil porque
alemania antes de la guerra incluso
antes de kobe tenía una situación de
superávit no en su en su presupuesto
público sin embargo no es el caso de
otros países como italia o francia misma
que tiene mucho más problemas tiene muy
poco margen de maniobra para poder dar
más ayudas a largo plazo a los
ciudadanos y como usted bien lo menciona
dentro de la unión europea hay países
que sufren de manera distinta esta
crisis energética y por eso han hecho un
llamado a que se actúe en bloque como
unión europea como tal tal como ocurrió
con la pandemia que tan posible es que
esto ocurra y por qué son las
dificultades de lograr unas medidas
conjuntas
felizmente para europea en el mercado
común de energía está muy bien
interconectado hay países que
efectivamente producen mucho más energía
que no depende del petróleo de gas pero
sin embargo que ellos van a depender de
justamente esa capacidad para poder
digamos sobrevivir al problema de no
tener acceso al gas barato de rusia
la cuestión es por el momento está
funcionando por el momento esa es esa
colaboración esa cooperación funciona
por ejemplo francés se comprometió a
entregar gas a alemania para que
alemania tenga una disponibilidad de gas
para hacer
funcionar sus centrales de gas la
cuestión es cuánto tiempo por ejemplo
porque de todas formas todos los países
europeos dependen en una medida una
cierta medida de gas o de petróleo
algunos más otros menos pero mismo esos
que dependen más y están realmente están
cortitos o sea que están justo justo en
su estoque de gas la cuestión es si
ellos van a tener que por encima
contribuir con
ayudar a otros países va a depender
entonces de las necesidades de cada uno
también todo dependerá de el acceso que
europa tenga a fuentes de gas o de
petróleo externas al continente como
eeuu los países del golfo e incluso
japón que hay
a parte de su reserva y usted menciona
estas fuentes alternas que ha buscado la
unión europea para no depender tanto ni
del petróleo y del gas ruso que tan
fuertes y que tanto han incrementado
estas fuertes fuentes alternas
o sea estaba hablando de fuentes
alternas de gas de petróleo de eeuu
golfo argelia etcétera el problemón eeuu
el más capaz de proveer es el petróleo y
el gas así como los países del magreb la
cuestión es que ni todos los países
europeos tienen la capacidad de
transformar el agua el gas licuado en
gas natural es para abuso directamente
en el continente solamente algunos
países tienen las plataformas y las
centrales de transformación que bueno
tardan 1 a 3 años en constituir alemania
está desesperada por eso ahora con
respecto a las alternas a las energías
alternativas como renovables etcétera
ya ya hace un año en las energías
renovables pasaron las energías fósiles
en generación energía en europa pero es
justo justo
la cuestión es que cada vez más se va a
utilizar este tipo energía energía
renovable y en europa sobre todo un
aumento mucho particularmente en
alemania es el recurso de la biomasa dow
y después la otra el otro tipo de
energía alternativa que está siendo muy
utilizada es el viento el problema es
que viento y solar son muy intermitentes
o sea que por más que la capacidad
instalada la potencia instalada de
generación es relativamente interesante
la capacidad es real de reducir eso
depende concretamente del clima
sí pero profundicemos en este punto y es
que la unión europea también volvió a
reactivar su producción de carbón ante
la escasez energética a pesar de que se
había comprometido para 2050 a ser la
primera región del mundo en lograr la
neutralidad de carbono ante esta crisis
que tanto se está alejando
europa de sus objetivos ambientales
todo depende de cuánto durará la crisis
o sea ese es el gran problema por el
momento se siguen la situación servir se
alarga por más de un año bueno el desvío
va a ser considerable sobre todo en
alemania
bueno aquí están quemando pero en las
carpetas ya que me hagan cargo na porque
al eliminar
reservar sus centrales nucleares
alemania empezó a irse más a las
renovables pero debido a la
intermitencia de la generación de
energía eólica o solar ellos quemaban ya
carbón con eso se intensificó y sobre
todo también en el este de europa si
esta guerra dura
más de un año probablemente europa va a
tener que abandonar esos esos objetivos
de reducción de dependencia del carbón
al mismo tiempo dentro de un año 23
europa va a tener una mayor capacidad de
recibir gas de otros países que no sean
rusos